2011 gegen das große rätselraten los, ein schatzsucher team hatte
ein
geheimnisvolles riesiges objekt auf dem meeresboden zwischen
Schweden und finnland in der ostsee entdeckt sein geschätzter durchmesser 60 meter. Und es ranken sich viele mysteriöse theorien
Um das angeblich versteinerte ufo das dem rasen im falken von star wars ziemlich
Allen, soll ist diese sogenannte ostsee. Anomalie tatsächlich bereits 140 1000
Jahre, alt und besteht aus materialien die es hier in der natur gar nicht gibt also fragen über fragen und die antworten
die gibt es jetzt wirklich zum science fiction
Herzlich willkommen zum. Blick zum und was soll ich sagen wieder
einen themenvorschlag von whatsapp fest steht in der baltischen see
Nördlich der schwedischen insel irland liegt in einer tiefe von etwa, 80 metern ein gigantisches kreisrundes objekt
das hat
Ein schwedisches schatzsucher das ocean tj maxx im juni 2011 entdeckt und weil sie nicht wussten was das rätselhafte objekt wirklich
Darstellt nannten sie es ostsee. Anomalie. Ein ferngesteuertes u-boot macht sich später bilder mit einer. Unterwasserkamera
Und mehr details kommen ans licht das objekt scheint zu sein also wirklich kreisrund allerdings mit einem 90 grad winkel
Und an einer stelle scheint man sogar eine treppe zu erkennen obendrauf befindet sich eine art kuppel
Ja ihr könnt euch vorstellen dass. Müsst. Ihr die fans esoteriker. Und
verschwörungstheoretiker
Ausflippen als sie diese ergebnisse auf einer pressekonferenz vorstellte doch das sind der schatzsucher betonte schon damals dass sie
Keine, ahnung hätten was sie dort gefunden hatten keineswegs. Bestand das team. Darauf dass es sich
Um, ein ufo handel doch das macht die ufo gemeinde noch hellhöriger
Genauso wie die. Aussage der schatzsucher dass
Ihre instrumente in der nähe der ostsee anomalie verrückt spielen würden die spekulationen gingen in alle möglichen richtungen, ein
ufo ein asteroid eine uralte zivilisationen oder
Hinweise auf atlantis aber auch die star wars fans waren außer sich
Um glaubten an einen millennium fig hatte han solos raumfrachter etwa
Einen unfall gab nun war trotz seines hyperraum antriebs in der ostsee gestrandet doch die bilder der unterwasserkamera waren eher verschwommen
Und unscharf und ließen eine genaue analyse nicht zu es gab spekulationen über eine art pfeiler die
Verschwörungstheoretiker auf den bildern entdeckt haben wollten zu hundertprozentiger sicherheit. Konnte die ostsee
Anomalie tatsächlich bis heute nicht identifiziert werden
Denn, das ging nur mit einer sehr kostspieligen unterwasser expedition auf einigen seiten im internet wird auch
Taucher verwiesen die mai 2017 proben von der ostsee. Anomalie bergen analysieren. Konnten mit einem
spektakulären ergebnis demnach enthält
Enthalten die proben metalle die die natur setzt sich reproduzieren kann auch diese expedition habe außerdem gezeigt dass
alle elektronischen geräte in der nähe des tatorts versagen die anhänger der sogenannten
ancient aliens also der
altertümlichen aliens eine unterabteilung der ufo fangemeinde quasi glauben fest
Daran dass aliens die erde vor langer zeit besucht haben von zehntausenden von. Jahren, hätte der außerirdischen
Besuch der menschheit überhaupt erst ermöglicht sich weiter. Zu entwickeln doch was sagen seriöse forschungsteams. Zu diesem ganzen ja studieren ganzen spekulationen
eine außerirdische sensation können wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler ausschließen
Bei dem gestein handelt es sich wohl, um basalt also
vulkanischen ursprungs und das würde zusammenpassen mit der entstehungsgeschichte
Der gesamten nord, baltischen region denn hier haben vor allem gletscher prozesse eine große rolle. Gespielt
Konkret vermuten forschungsteams hier so genannte drops ton. Steine sind wohl von den schmelzenden eis schon
Gefallen, und auf den meeresgrund gesunken möglicherweise könnte es sich auch. Um einen
vulkankrater haldern auch die schatzsucher selbst sind mittlerweile der meinung dass es sich bei der ostsee anomalie wohl, um,
Mineralisches, um, ein mineralisches gebilde handelt ja also wenn ihr kein video dazu und auch
Zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollte die youtube autobots funktioniert ja nicht richtig. Dann endet. Mich bei whatsapp nur dann verpasst er kein video
Und über whatsapp erfahrt. Ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich und garantiert einfach hier draufklicken es geht
Auch mit anderen messen. John, und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks. Um, social media abonnieren da gibt es im neuesten video
Um den prozess über den volks lehrer hier auf youtube der ja die. Ein oder andere verschwörungstheorie
Hier verbreitet dafür hier draufklicken aber nicht die genau glocke vergessen. Und hier geht es war damit
Dafür auch draufklicken, ufo-sichtungen da geht es. Um die staatliche ufo forschung in den usa bis. Dann
bleibt dran